this is a production of Cornell
University
so well thank you for this invitation I
have to give a bit of an a disclaimer
that so I'm going to give really is kind
of a public relations event so I'm going
to give it a talk that is a version of a
talk that I gave at the bti I'm very
well amplified it feels um and that it's
a Magna Ling Lindbergh who invited me to
come give it again here and so I'm going
to point to one vision of the
opportunities and try to illustrate it
with projects that i know of around
campus around heavily the college of
engineering but also physical sciences
and i'll put in a few projects that from
published work from other places in the
world and i'll start out with a naive
outsider's perspective on why why plant
scientists might look more to these
emerging and future physical science
tools if I'm offensive it'd be good if
you told me because so I won't continue
to be offensive about my assumptions
about the state of plant science and
important questions so I come to this
having interacted with a plant
scientists here and elsewhere but also
having been part of a a big growth area
at Cornell in looking at engineering
questions in biology and I was very
naive early on to thinking that but not
completely wrong in thinking that there
are a lot of similarities between the
organism scale as well as the cellular
and molecular scale of mammalian systems
and plant systems now that's of course
of a very coarse view but in terms of
Technology Development there's
reason to believe that the analogies can
be powerful and there may be translation
from one to the other now why bring up
mammals in a plant science department
well is because they the mammalian
biologists in particular in the
biomedical field have heavily engaged
engineers in technology development to a
level that i think is well maybe scales
with the size of human biology relative
to plant science but there has been a
lot of technology development in these
past decades and so one way to say is
why not bring by nanotechnology and
other technologies to plant science well
one is that they they've gone to human
biology they've gone from being
molecular tools through cellular tools
to being clinical tools that have our
interfaces with the living organism so
it doesn't have to be dissected and I'll
point to some of these examples that
ought to be able to be translated in
some form to plant biology and
agriculture now working in attempts to
bring technology to plants I understand
also that there are important
differences that in some ways it's
harder plants don't let you in as easily
they don't have soft skin often and
disrupting them can have dire
consequences that and in some ways
mammalian systems are more agreeable to
some of these interventions okay I
highlight the hypodermic needle because
this is one of the absolute workhorses
of human of biomedical intervention and
I would argue that essentially we don't
have a hypodermic needle for plants and
they're important reasons why we don't
but we it'd be awful nice if we did so
agriculture I think a lot of people
think of engineering in implant sciences
being things you stick to a tractor and
I think that's been the definition of
for many decades and it still is in
and an important target and one way to
see it is one one thing that is
surprised me i was first surprised to
know how heavily agriculture is invested
in smart irrigation strategies 10
million at Hector's is a reasonably a
recent estimate for globally and yet
almost never is that on a closed loop
feedback because they don't ask the
plants how much water they want or ask
even the soil and so here you have what
is an advanced approach running free
running on somebody's intuition about
what what should be going on in terms of
irrigation and it's and if for example
and these are topics that I'm interested
in its uninformed by parameters that are
relatively coarse but I have been shown
to be crucially important like water
potential stem water potential that it's
been shown that you know crop
productivity quality correlate with this
one simple seeming parameter in the
plant and yet we have no practical way
to go and ask even a sampling of plants
in the field what their water stress
levels are today the techniques of our
now mostly 60 years old and course and
manual and hard to use not giving you
real time data I think there's it
important advances have been going on in
remote sensing I think that and they can
give beautiful information I think there
I'd like to see is bringing into the
plant getting local physiological data
into that potential feedback loop the
other another place that I've been
learning more recently what the
realities today are about breeding
programs and selection of a better crops
and here's it seems to me a beautiful
challenge for the engineering community
that most engineers have no idea about
and it took me a number of years working
with plant scientists but for truly
learning the realities of what it is to
select a better plant and so here I'm
showing science fiction a patch on that
you could a few sent patch that you
could go along and put on many many
crosses for example and get something
local physiological back during the
growing season outside and it was
actually a partly meeting with ed
buckler that crystallized this challenge
for me he he and this is a paraphrase
but basically told me if you can measure
a trait 10,000 times I'll find you the
gene and I made you know better than I
whether he's correct about that it looks
from his publication record like could
well be true and again this this
challenge thousands of reproducible
quantitative measurements on plants
that's a great challenge and it's one
that engineers should know about should
be going after because I think it's
possible not for every a definition of a
trait every phenotype every protein but
for some crucial ones and this I gotta
say I saw talk by pioneer and they and
they it was maybe he was retired from
pioneer and he admitted that in his
opinion leaf angle had been the biggest
change in phenotype that had defined
increases in yields in their breeding
program and that may be an
oversimplification but I i was shocked
that that's what these extraordinarily
sophisticated molecular biologists deal
with extremely course physiological
information extremely coarse definitions
of what a trait is and I can understand
why because you have to measure it
thousands of times you have to measure
it in complicated environments but again
it's a
it's it's in some sense that it's the
engineer and of the problem that's
failed in this project because I know
that the molecular tools are incredible
but if you're applying molecular tools
that the absolute state of the art and
genetic analysis to leaf angle that
seems unfortunate so I know so we have a
very naive again of perspective on what
the molecular and cellular questions in
plant biology are and so I'm just giving
one example here where I see opportunity
and then again I was surprised to learn
about the state of knowledge and plants
is here's an example of its a review
saying that a direct evidence of a
demotion or the movement of a peptide
has yet been to not been achieved in the
lab and that this particular flowering
locus t is the in 2013 was said to be
the only example of long-range signaling
by a protein in the plant in a plan and
this seems like again it this is a
challenge across biological fields but
to integrate information extremely
sophisticated information about
individual cells and molecular processes
with organism scale processes this is a
place where in by in biomedical
engineering there's been a lot of it's
been a rich area for making progress to
get to the tissue scale get to the
organism scale with hypotheses about
with molecular hypotheses and so it's
another opportunity so I'm going to talk
about three perspectives on how and I'm
going again I'm going to illustrate them
with lots of people's work I'm going to
talk about what I call devices and this
is where Cornell has been a leader in
developing small scale devices and a lot
of that energy of in the time I've been
a core
has been pointed towards human health
not much of it pointed towards plant
science and I think that's a missed
opportunity to date Cornell is also
extremely good and in imaging and I know
many of you probably use it advanced
imaging techniques but I think this is
that this has been continued to be
leaders in the world in in advanced
imaging techniques and then also models
I models that I'm going to focus on not
bioinformatics like models but more what
we call systems biology models which
again look to integrate information from
the molecular across to the the cellular
and to the physiol the full animal full
organisms physiology so I'm going to
start with devices and I'll just point
out that there's a Cornell has a
tradition in this one of the workhorses
of soil science and agriculture still
today was invented here there's some
argument about precedent but the the
Richard soil tensiometer is still a the
only tool to measure precisely across on
the plant physiological range of drought
stress the few bars of tension that are
relevant to most agriculturally relevant
plants this is it versions of this
technology I think many most of you know
the the gene gun and of course both of
these came from cows they didn't come
from the engineering college so that's I
admit that but I think these are these
are two technologies historic
technologies that came out of Cornell
that our precedent for what should be
being done here still today so I'm going
to turn to a number of technologies did
I I don't know of being used in plants
but I think could be interesting and so
this urban development is a new fact
member in biomedical engineering and
this is something he he's working on
today and this is a publication be
published just before he came here uh
and this is an example of using a
microfluidic system which is a
miniaturized lab that can handle
extremely small scale samples to collect
a single-stranded DNA out of the blood
and it turns out that is an important in
the context of transplant a biology of
transplants but this is one of many
examples of doing molecular biological
analysis on what would have previously
been thought of as being unusable
samples the contents of a single cell
you can do analysis on the contents of a
single cell today it's still that's
still a challenge but it's that it's the
kind of advance that is represented by
nanobiotechnology this is an example
from Harold craighead Kraig heads group
in Applied Physics he is up I think
maybe the person who coined the name
nanobiotechnology when he started the
nanotech biotechnology Center here at
Cornell and one of the big themes has
been manipulation of biomacromolecules
in particular DNA that has led to the
beginnings of or the what is now
becoming a reality of single molecule
sequencing and this is an example I
believe this is an example of mapping
epigenetic change at the single
molecular scale and so what you see here
is what nano this is a truly this here
are the features that were created in
Cornell's nano fab or of a molecular
dimension and forcing this DNA to take
on a confirmation that allows it to be
literally read with microscopy this is
another example from applied physics of
creating a cell culture that has a that
allows electrophysiology to be done with
subcellular resolution so this involves
both the traditional patch-clamp type
approach but also the cell
is living on a circuit that allows the
group to interface with it and watch for
events that occur it to triangulate to
wear this event recurring on a sub a
subcellular scale moving up a little bit
and a number of these ideas are about
cultured tissues and cells and i know
this is there's a difference in how
important that is in plant biology than
in mammalian biology but i think i hope
that some of these examples trigger some
ideas about where the translation could
occur so this is an example from Mike
Schuler's group who I still claim him
from my department he's actually shared
with a biomedical engineering and this
is an example of in fact building a
mimic a replica of the connectivity of
tissues in a mammalian system and so you
see here liver fat kidney um and
coupling them with a very primitive
vascular system but one that allows the
metabolic environment in the signaling
to interact with these different tissues
in a manner that simulates time scales
and transformations that occur in the
different tissues in the in the body and
so this this type of replication of
tissue properties of the tissue
environment is something that there's a
lot of there's a lot of know-how now
both from the material side the
fabrication side and in some cases the
biological side about what are the
influences of the the tissue environment
and the communication between tissues
within a full organism this is an
example again that is called a tissue
engineering effort from my lab of folk a
focus on the micro vascular structure of
of humans which is um like the flow i'm
in a plant
is built of living cells okay the
vessels on the small scale are really
formed of a single layer of endothelial
cells that have a huge amount of biology
associated with them and of course it's
a bottleneck for forming any big tissue
is to simultaneously form its vascular
system if you're going to do an
engineering process to form a tissue um
I generally and I've spoken to very few
people about this but I wonder I would
seem our naively that tissue engineering
um might happen be a whole lot more fun
and easy in plants in some ways that
creating and because plants might just
go with it and there may not be there's
not the clinical vision of bringing
somebody a lab grown heart but actually
today much of tissue engineering is done
to recreate a multi cellular structure
to study it study its biology at that
multicellular scale without they're very
few examples today of translation truly
to the clinic and so in that same spirit
I could imagine that it could be
interesting for in plant biology here's
a effort that i thought was exciting
from from Northwestern for northeastern
not from Cornell but it's an example
another example of creating a micro
environment and in this case also again
what we call a microfluidic system that
has micro scale features at inside this
cartridge and this is they by creating
that environment and in bearing in the
soil they were able to grow up a huge
number of uncultivated microbes and from
that they managed to isolate an abaya
promising antibiotics that were had been
unseen previously because if you just
took the soil you had to
little too little of any one species to
produce that small molecule um and so
this is uh I wish it I wish it had been
an idea here or but it's an example that
I think it's worth noting that one one
place and in fact Harvey Hoch as that
plant pathologist was one of the early
people to interact with the nano
biotechnology Center one of the most
active biologists at the nano
biotechnology Center and the one reason
to recreate these mimics or replicas
these engineered tissues may it may be
more about pathology than it is about
the plant biology on its own okay here
is one of the first efforts that first
targets that my group went after was to
build synthetic xylem and because plants
do something that engineers don't that
humans basically don't which is use
liquids under tension and so we made
very very simple replicas and it was
really more about a materials question
of how to build a network that coupled
to the outside in a way that allow the
the the fluid in these tiny vessels to
go under tension in the manner that's
proposed by CT cohesion tension theory
and it turns out that it's we from us in
a synthetic system validated cohesion
tension theory which has nice
consequences physically there's brings
us into a new regime physically but I
think it also gives us an opportunity to
for example understand the the design
ideas from the purely physical point of
view of the year for example the
segmented xylem structure seeing these
events of embolization occurring
independently as has all along been
proposed for the redundant segmented
structure of xylem I've also thought
that and I've spoke to Harvey about this
before he retired that this creates an
unusual environment the environment
the xylem in the leaf for example where
important pathogens live that is unlike
any other environment in the world so
what is it like to be a microbe that
lives with the fluid pressure around it
going from 0 to minus 20 bars up and
down and up and down and so it's also
potentially a bioreactor environment to
study the biology of plant pathogen
interactions one of the things we've
done with this and this was a Alan lack
so we were building a device that
extrapolated from our synthetic tree to
put ought to have a cavity of liquid
with and this is it's a strange geometry
but this grey area around is a
nanoporous membrane that allows the
liquid in this cavity to go to tension
when when it's exposed to a dry
environment and here we were building it
to have direct mechanical sensing so
that we would have a direct measure of
that stress and Alan came to find out
what what this synthetic tree was and so
on and when we showed him this that we
were building as a laboratory to study
liquids under tension he said although
that's a tensiometer and we hadn't known
about Richard and the whole challenge of
tense geometry I till that point and we
realized that this was in fact a
miniature Richards tensiometer and again
I like I told you we've come to
appreciate that that tensiometer
measuring drought stress as a stress as
a tension is the most sensitive way to
measure that thermodynamic state of
water and so having your a strain gauge
on a diaphragm over this cavity allows
us to have quantitative measures of the
water potential in the environment
around this device and in this case this
is an this is our champion of this
generation of these devices we measured
it went to an embolization event at 300
bars of of tension for a water potential
of minus 300 bars and just to get this
is I don't know if this will
maybe to actually see I don't know which
of these work but to actually see
embolization is fun that this is the
release this is the cliq that acoustic
measurements here this dramatic release
of of the tension upon embolization and
so it turns out we've been continued
with Alan and Taryn to pursue this so
that it's a truly practical for a plant
science measurements and so here is our
current generation of this device which
is as you can see here down to a
relatively small package I'm failing to
get a pointer here and this in this
format it's just it's like a pinky a
pinky fingernail and it turns out one of
the nice things is that I like is it to
make it respond fast enough to be able
to catch all of the changes in water
potential that might be occurring in a
plant which is where we'd like to take
Richard tensiometer and move it into the
stem instead of being purely for the
soil is we had to give it a vascular
system we had to connect this cavity to
the outside world with vessels that
would as in plants as in the xylem
tissue transmit the stress maintain the
stress so be there divided from the
outside world by membranes by nanoporous
membranes but once inside this device
fluid moves extremely rapidly along
these vessels and so the idea of
segmented xylem allowed us to take from
our first prototypes our first
generation these devices very long
transients it would have meant we
wouldn't capture things that occurred in
less than an hour to having just few
just tens of second transients that
allow us we think to capture all diurnal
and so on behavior of
plan and to do it across a bring the
Richard tensiometer II idea out towards
a hundred bar so all across all the way
to really desert stresses in plants and
we actually have just moved this into a
into plant tissue and we have a trees
growing in the greenhouse that so here
working in branch segments these are
actually just in the last week to
actually measure where we apply drying
stresses on to the this branch segment
and can watch what we've been calling in
the lab diurnal although they're not
they're just tens of minutes long and
their associated with not with true
transpiration but within post
transpiration but we are hoping that
this will allow us and in a process in
an embedding process your designed for a
woody species that just takes a few
minutes to get a real time long-term
stress information on plants and as part
of water relations research and
eventually as part of irrigation
scheduling to close that feedback loop
with what is a very relevant way to do
it the plants actual stress and this is
just a zoom to see we were getting we
can able to resolve on ten tens of bar
scale we can resolve small fractions of
one bar changes in water potential which
of course for annual species may be the
more relevant scale just a few bars
instead of tens of bars so that's a
that's an example of actually bringing
one of these technologies to a plant
here's coming to a leader in the world
of making electronic sophisticated
electronics compatible with life John
Rogers group which is now moved to
Northwestern and this is an example of
what I think I pointed to the idea of an
RFID chip or patch on every leaf of
field of plants and this is this is an
example on human of human application of
a real
grated circuitry on a flexible adhesive
patch that gives you on this case
electrophysiological data through the
skin of this of the wearer and so I
don't know of anybody moving this into
plants but if again with the right
inspiration from from you I'm sure it
could happen moving towards the field
bringing these things from research
questions to the field is certainly a
place where there's lots of expertise on
campus you may have seen this this is a
work from the Erickson group and
mechanical engineering where they have a
term that's turned a iphone into a
relatively sophisticated sensor
diagnostic system for metabolic diseases
and symptoms and so this is an example
of engineering all the way towards
something you can hand off to a
non-expert user and bring to the field
and do diagnostics and again there's
this this type of idea from once you
have the idea of a lab on an iPod or I
lab on an iPhone you you can there's no
reason not to bring it to a question
about a biochemical question implants we
have a very large very strong electrical
engineering department this is an
example of Edwin Khan who isn't at is
very much focused on this question of
completely wireless power free sensing
so all those patches may not even need a
battery as with the checkout counter
RFID an RFID is just an antenna it picks
up the energy it needs to respond to you
just from the radiation you send attic
and so this again is it somebody be if
you have sensors already and what you
need is to have 10,000 of them that all
talk to you there's that expertise on
campus so that was my longest section
I'll just give a few examples
of imaging capabilities we have one of
our imaging experts here Becky Williams
there there is a very good shared
facility in while and in across in a
biotech building I'm going to highlight
one of the things I've very exciting
recently which is a collaboration of
matt patrick and more in zip file
they're developing advanced versions of
the mic of the microscopy that i'm
showing here and this is a mammalian
example but it's a super resolution
technique and what they are able what
we're seeing here it's hard to maybe
read this scale bar what we're seeing in
the z-direction deformations of the
cells plasma membrane of tens of
nanometers okay and so this cartoon the
boats in this micrograph are associated
with individual or small clusters of
transmembrane binding proteins
interacting with the substrate and so
this is one of the things going from
pure structure to two dynamics in the
current efforts and it's a huge
possibility to watch interactions at the
plasma membrane one molecule 11
transmembrane protein at a time this is
an example that you may have heard about
recently aleve user got a very large
national institute of health grant for
this effort uh it's in this case he's
the star of this picture is this a
little sphere here which can be just a
few nanometers across and carries with
it the ability can carry with it of
fluorescence and chemistry that allow it
to be a detector okay in this case
they're using it to carry contrast agent
for an imaging but they've worked on
this in many different directions these
little lab on a particle is an
opportunity to have a truly dispersible
sensor that could be go to the tissue in
an intact plant go to the tissue where
you want it and then be read out
spectroscopically for example but by
fluorescence
an example and not from Cornell but from
this field of so-called nanomaterials
here from Michael stron OHS group at MIT
of disrupting a chloroplast with a
nanotube and what he finds with this
simple my simple understanding is
essentially by putting this carbon
nanotubes which is just a few nanometers
in diameter and has tunable electrical
properties he's essentially putting an
antenna into this organelle within the
cell and changing and this is him
piercing a single chloroplast and
getting a different getting an infrared
signal from that chloroplast it was
invisible before he put it in they go on
in this paper to claim that this is
improved photosynthetic efficiency in
these leaves that were treated with I
have some worry about that claim but the
idea that gehen of having a almost
molecular scale engineered material that
can be part of transducing information
from the cellular scale or even
influencing the behavior at the cell and
subcellular scale i think is interesting
so models again i'm going to looking
towards models that are i know there's a
lot of expertise in cals and in plant
science in bioinformatics modeling i'm
less familiar with modeling of gene
expression coupled the kinetics of gene
expression coupled to signaling coupled
to a cellular behavior coupled to
transport processes on the organism
scale and that's a that's one definition
of systems and systems biology that i
think is very relevant to plants and so
we might sooner again here i gave him
both his department's biomedical
engineering and chemical engineering is
actually famous in this community as a
very early a developer of complete
treatments of
cell behavior here starting with
microbes bacteria but what I mean by
complete in this case the definition of
the complete is that he has a set of
differential equations that are
self-sustaining alive and respond to
metabolic stimuli and so on in a way
that is reasonable including gene
regulation okay and so going from gene
regulation gene expression through to
metabolism those are tractable there are
a large number of tractable model models
for prokaryotes and eukaryotes to be
worked with to ask a questions jeff
varner in my department is uh somebody
who is one of the people who push this
to extremes of of completeness in terms
of the number of molecular players
they're willing to put into such a model
of the cell again going from going from
gene expression signaling internally and
with the external environment and in
this case moving to a multiscale
consideration of how a cell evolved in
its tissue context and so with signals
coming from other parts of the tissue
and through vasculature for example
other other parts of the organism a
highlight effort with Bob Turgeon that
I've been involved in on the questions
of phloem loading and here's an example
of we're focused on the the biochemistry
associated with phloem loading and
transport questions very detailed
questions about plasma des metal the
physics of plasma desmona des mada and
how they regulate what goes what gets
loaded and we do this we claim and I
believe that we understanding the
implicit
nations the design ideas that are
represented by plasmodesmata requires
some accounting for the full organism
scale coupling that this is what the
concentrations water potentials that
define transport very locally in the at
the mesophyll phloem interface in the
leaf are coupled to throughout the
entire plant and so that again is an
example of where a different levels of
what could be defined as a systems
biological approach can lead to
hypotheses that then lead to experiments
and it's a it's it's a useful a cup
iterative process that I think is not
done enough so I just there here I can
share these slides are a number of other
people across the university um that
most of whom have not thought to apply
their skills to plant science but um I
think number of them would be happy to
and there are again lots of resources I
this talk was originally a code talk
with the Center for nano scale physic
nanoscale science and technology the CNF
but I'd also point to the and I believe
they're represented here the center for
material science which is like the CNF
an extremely robust long long-term
effort which in particular for example
has some of the best microscopists in
the world and the absolute best tem
facilities that can be had in academia
and this is actually lina is a recently
arrived and recently acquired a 34
million dollar transmission electron
microscope and is very interested in
biological questions so to summarize
either i there are opportunities that go
from the very most basic molecular
biology through to
something that will be coupled to
something strapped to an attractor I
think that and there's it'd be very nice
to see the kind of interactions vigorous
interactions that have been going on
between engineers and human health
biologists going on between engineers
and plant biologists for if there any
decision makers in the audience one of
the things that helped a whole lot early
on where seed grants that we had no
collaborations with wild cornell medical
school and then there started to just
sprinkle on these 50 kc grants once a
year and it was amazing how quickly that
changed now of course biomedical
engineering also grew a whole program
but i think there's uh there's reason
for this kind of interaction i think
could lead to a lot of activity so that
i'd like to thank my group a number of
people a number of collaborators
including those here i think bob i have
not gotten you on my collaborator yet
list yet we got to get those papers out
but that wasn't because of that but so
thank you very much for your attention
and i'll be happy to take any questions
so it's an important encoder sensors
yeah well that's that that's great but
it's not always that anything readable
and so I think a better and more overt
or zip fell over in or wanton ways to
read those centuries return city and of
course always systems to work phone
percenter better and work out tricks to
calibrate them and so that's a good
thing that I do think there are visible
silence steps that animal cells applying
the vessels activity in the Cypress
components
besides of student by Perkins permeable
and gentlemen silence from enter the
room and so that but what that dimension
is is not as we saw us each dependent
and not all share price and I think
someone's there you're smaller to real
data suddenly knows when you'll better
about optical particulate but but it is
it is a trick and that again and can't
just like people to go silent it's
poverty so you mentioned kind of the
different scales of plant vs mammalian
travel so we like a small corner eating
trial might be 10,000 plants which would
be an absolutely massive crowd on rats
much less students I guess what are kind
of in terms of these technologies in
mammalian systems for tissue sensing
what are the largest scales that people
work on and how could that
for the skills that you have something
like the cereals my people well so
they're 22 so if you given the buttons
on here breeding programs you can get
people if it enough to make it enough
sensors than their costs would go very
low so I make enough of my life sensors
to satisfy breeders they think they
already use them I bring the cost that
sensor down to two very expensive get
advantage from the scale of Christ oh so
that's one if there is a if there is a
real rebel is that you carry
supercomputer in pocket cool what you
wanted out so that the other respect is
that some of these approaches around of
so-called narratives these are can be
synthesized by any
scale and so they could be if the
deliberative workout that can and
there's the one reader strapless one
tracker might be able to review all
plans and I never paint ever need but
must worried something like some suction
interactionism everything one of those
10,000 species like that so it's not
today I know if I had a son but the 10
valve replicas of an experiment our
feelings is the child is a good one so
I'm saying and I'm hoping I'm trying to
articulate that district in the end to
impunity hopefully the 20 community that
the investment provided is this deposit
look what is the in your really need
from what to measure and it's not just
your dream but what is it too
comfortable commonality perfect piece of
metal nation and what would scale and so
and by hitting is the readers why can't
anything go they don't think my they
don't and this is the team to trade gap
they're so focused on the gene
identification that they're not very
much part about transplant could they
could get beyond the fanboy
and there are curious things that would
potentially listen so I once we explore
something for example trying to show me
the robot sees the proboscis of go
through without losing a clot and so
this oughta be dropped capable and
there's been a huge feather on
microneedle drug and so it's extremely
fine so it's like an adult I've head of
a truncated many times over to catch
your service so I that yes ether isn't
too I think looking to the viola violin
so I can also species like this nicole
it grows itself into tissue without
disrupting the biochemistry allowed to
do that crisp the suppression of plant
response those are filtered part i think
what's going to happen allowed her
graceful interface
yeah yeah yeahs to you I mean fo'c'sle
on mechanical properties before plants
are engaged a lot of exotic chemistry as
well you thought about sort of
technologies that might be used to for
the big sense of discovery nomicon house
or something like that yeah absolutely
and so I and so for example and and and
in the example that shown much of the
voice thing about who is also 509 459
commons and small margins I in terms of
analysis with small samples on small
scales which devices now is a big part
of what from home lab on chip effort is
thin and so whether the volatiles around
the plant force small little sibling
with in tissues it's a good heart it's
not what am I only has been focusing on
but there's a lot on campus in that not
a little chemistry scaled down a does
give us a number of really
and
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu